in time shadow health secretary is with
us now we're straightening good morning
good morning
talk to me about why first of all uh
your leader has pulled out of uh a
speech at the institute for government
today no idea i didn't check for coming
on so i thought it's such a trivial
thing um but the idea that as i've
obviously done a couple of these
interviews this morning the idea that
kiera's been avoiding scrutiny when he's
been out all weekend in front of cameras
celebrating those brilliant results we
got in the local elections last week um
you know it's
like whether or not he's done an event
his diary changed all the time he's kind
of neither here nor there really
wouldn't it have been a perfect
opportunity for him to clear the air
with journalists and everyone else that
wanted to hear what happened in april of
last year well he's been doing that all
weekend he's been doing it consistently
uh since
he was first asked questions about
durham and let's just remember this
central fact which is the police have
looked at this before they found no case
to answer no action was taken there's no
reason to think this time round will be
any different but what it will show
is the stark contrast between boris
johnson who was fined boris johnson who
lied about there being any events
whatsoever under his own roof
boris johnson who said all of that
despite the fact we now know that
officials were wheeling in suitcases
full of booze into number ten there is
there is no comparison whatsoever
between perfectly legitimate campaigning
activity which kier has never denied
and the actions of boris johnson the
people who work for him which was rule
breaking lying completely unacceptable
and the fact that boris johnson is still
there i think is
remarkable and depressing and if
conservative mps last time i was on your
program i said conservative mps have got
to do the right thing hold boris johnson
to account or they fail to do that but
maybe last week's results in the local
election campaign and the loss of
hundreds of conservative councillors
might concentrate their minds so that if
tory mps aren't going to do the right
thing for the right reasons maybe
they'll do the right thing out of
self-preservation meantime back to what
your boss was up to um he told us um at
the time and subsequently that it was a
spontaneous curry from this document
that we've seen that was leaked by a
whistleblower who was obviously very
upset by him
and the actions of the party it wasn't a
spontaneous curry it was planned i think
we've got it we were told that angela
rayna was not there she was there
and we were told for months that she
wasn't there she was there she was quite
obviously there her name was on the list
we were told that um he returned to work
afterwards it looks from the briefing
notes that that would suggest otherwise
and we were told that um 15 people were
there and one has to ask why was that
reasonably necessary what were two
things one is um it was a genuine
cock-up a genuine mistake to say that
angela rainer wasn't there but let's
just look at this
it was a genuine mistake and let's just
bear in mind there would be nothing to
gain whatsoever for saying that kier
starmer was at this event and angela
rainer wasn't not least because no rules
were broken this is perfectly legitimate
and as for this i mean one of the things
i thought was remarkable and you know i
mean credit to the male's imagination
they've managed to turn a perfectly
normal
ops note for a visit to um during an
election into some kind of great
revelation what do they think people
happen that we go on visits and just
wander around the town like in the hope
we might just do something useful we
were told it was spontaneous the food
it's there it's on the ops note take
away from spice laundry
he couldn't get food from anywhere else
he went to the hotel there was food
available i am i am i am you know
breaking news kierstarma has dinner kia
starman needs to eat dinner of course he
of course they've arranged dinner and
you know i'm not surprised that
i'm not surprised that it's there you
told us that angela rainer wasn't there
all of this was planned you know as with
all things it's never the cock-up it's
always the cover-up but hang on a second
are we seriously saying
that we believe
that kirsten is his and his team have
planned an event and planned a meal in
there which they knew to be breaking the
rules
i think this is ridiculous that kirsten
is someone who practices what he
preaches he's honest
and it's perfectly reasonable to have a
dinner this is perfectly permissible
within the rules and i've got no doubt
that after the dinner he went back to
work because anyone who's ever worked on
an election campaign knows that you work
late into the evening and i know from
working with kierstarma he works late in
the evening all the time and and i just
i mean
the police but the police or the police
will look before they draw their
conclusions
i don't think people out there in the
country think that kia stammer is the
kind of bloke who goes around breaking
the rules and getting smashed on an
election campaign breaking the rules i
mean this is why i just think this is
all stretching the boundaries of
credibility and i'm frustrated because
all this is about is trying to let me
get a word on edgewood if it was
permissible uh why didn't he say why did
he not agree why did he not tell us
about all of this to start with instead
of coming up with some [ __ ] and ball
story but i don't i don't think that's i
don't think that's a fair
characterization
i think that's fair uh and he prompted
curry because he couldn't get food
anywhere else we know that that's not
true we were told that uh angela rainer
was not there we can see that wasn't
true but it was a in in the angela
rainer case it was a genuine mistake and
the late party held its hands up and
said look we're really sorry correctly
straight away rather than monkey
well you know obviously someone didn't
check at the time and that was stupid
and the labour party apologized and held
our hands up and i think that's the
right way to behave and look that is a
stark contrast by the way with boris
johnson who lied regularly and
repeatedly denied there were any events
in number 10 whatsoever any rule
breaking whatsoever and then we found
out not only were rules broken under his
own roof he was there and he was
breaking the rule so look the police
looking at this now i don't think
they'll draw any different conclusions
the one they did before but they are
looking at it and i think in the end
kiersten will be vindicated and people
will end up looking very silly so uh
when the prime minister was under
investigation kia stammer
said that his position was untenable
this is when he was under investigation
not about when he was actually uh found
himself in a position where he had
broken the rules he said honesty and
decency matter after months of denials
the prime minister is now under criminal
investigation which uh key stamina is
for breaking his own lockdown laws he
needs to do the direct the decent thing
and resign that's what he said in a
tweet and that was in january of this
year's so this was for being under
investigation not for actually
breaking
kia was absolutely right and and the
reason why boris johnson should have
resigned then it was because because
even before even before
no no hang on a second even before the
police drew their conclusions and issued
a fine we already knew that boris
johnson had lied to parliament because
we already knew that parties had taken
place so boris johnson had already been
caught lying to parliament and under the
ministerial code no he looked the key
was discriminating he'll investigate
yeah he's drawing he's drawing attention
to the fact that prime minister is under
criminal investigation but that but you
know he he was already calling for the
resignation anyway because because
foreign criminal investigation honesty
and decency matter so if it was good
enough for the prime minister it's good
enough for him and the police have
looked at kyr's case before and i've no
doubt that they will reach the same
conclusion this time and he's under
criminal investigation honesty and
decency matter they they do honesty and
decency do matter and i think their
qualities that kierstarma epitomizes i
believe he's told the truth the way
through i believe he's followed the
rules at all time and i believe that
when the police look at this again as
they are we'll cooperate fully i think
they're going to draw the same
conclusion and that would
strengthen the contrast honesty and
decency after months of denial as the
prime minister is now i'm under criminal
investigations people read that same
tweet i'll give you a different answer
look i can't what are you saying that
having not broken the rules kierstarma
should resign while the bloke in number
10 he broke the rules
he's saying that one rule for him and
one rule for them no he's absolutely not
no
okay you've got to remember back at the
time in you know january 2022 we already
knew that boris johnson had been caught
bang to right lying to parliament we
were already
on that basis you know calling for boris
johnson to go so i don't i don't accept
that because the police are now looking
at this again
having had
you know weeks and weeks of the
conservatives and others calling for
them to do so i don't believe that
kierstama should be handing in his
resignation because the police are
looking at it the police looked at it
before there's no reason to think
they'll reach a different conclusion
this time what i do think is remarkable
is that the leader who did break the
rules who did lie who did mislead
parliament who did pretend nothing was
going on who did take the people for
fools and who did allow his officials to
wheel in suitcases for the booze is
still there can you accept at least that
this is not aged well
no i think it's perfectly reasonable
thing to say stand by every single word
that keir said back then okay let me put
it this way then if
given that durham police are now
reinvestigating your leader should they
also be reinvestigating what happened
with dominic cummings
well why not but look i'm not going to
tell the police what to do in terms of
operational policing decisions i don't
think it's appropriate for senior
politicians because you're saying that
they won't find a case rather than
waiting to see what they say no i'm
saying what i think will happen i'm not
saying police you must not find there's
a case to answer i'm saying i have
confidence on the basis of what i know
and on the basis of the man that i know
in kierstarma his honesty his decency
and integrity i think the police will
reach the same conclusion they did last
time but as i've as i've always said
about the police they need to pursue um
things without fear or favor and i'm
sure that's what they'll do and i make
no criticism for them what if he gets a
fixed penalty notice i don't think he
will i'm not even going to entertain the
prospects we'll have weeks and weeks of
the tourist slinging mud at kierstama
hoping that people will just conclude
that we're all the same there's no point
in changing prime ministers because the
next one would be as bad as the current
one and that's just not true and i'm not
going to get into the game that the
tories are playing with their friends in
the media
of trying to smear a decent man and to
pretend that kia stalma's behavior is in
any way comparable with boris johnson
and how conservatives have the
bare-faced cheek to come out you know
gloating and demanding resignations and
throwing around accusations of hypocrisy
a decent man like kirsten i don't know
they should get their own house in order
if not for decency and honesty and
public life but for those hundreds of
conservative councillors who lost their
seats because their prime minister's a
liar okay um you're not going to answer
this either but i'm going to ask you um
why aren't they this guy's the one i
will answer well let's see if you will
you may you may you know you were always
surprised
um do you want to be next leader
we've got a list of all of the ones i i
i'm sure that women that might i'm sure
that by the time there is a leadership
election i'll be too old and people will
be looking to a new generation because
after three terms of kirsten being the
prime minister of our country people
would be looking so you don't fancy
being prime minister or a leader of the
no i'm i'm i'm not any surprise i'm
slogging my guts out to make sure that
kirsten was the next prime minister on
the basis of the election results we got
last week a remarkable turnaround from
where labour was two years ago i think
we've got everything to play for the
next general election and i think when
people look at kierstarma look at the
values he holds looks at the answers
that we have to the country on things
like the cost of living crisis the two
million people that we now know are
cutting back on food can't afford to eat
a labor government will deliver the
alternative our country needs and that
government will be led by kirsten okay
well that's the topic that we're going
on to next it's great to see you thank
you thank you indeed thanks for joining
us